Voiceover: What i want to do in this video
is dig a little bit deeper
in this marginal product revenue curve,
and really make sure we understand
what it's telling us,
that it really is the
marginal benefit curve
for this firm.
In the video we constructed,
this firm is a car wash.
Also, how we can use this to think about
what's a rational number of people
for this firm to hire?
Just as a reminder, this
horizontal axis here,
this is a quantity of labor per hour,
so this is people per hour
that are working at the firm.
People per hour.
And the vertical axis here,
the marginal product revenue,
that you could view as
the marginal dollars,
or the incremental dollars
that you're getting
per person, per hour.
Per person, per hour,
per hour.
And to just verify that it's
telling us the same thing
visually that this table
told us right up here,
we can think about what is the marginal,
how much incremental revenue do we get
from hiring that 1st person.
What we could do is we
could multiply the quantity
of people,
which is 1,
times the average,
times the average increment,
the average marginal product revenue
that we get from 1 person,
or I should say, the average we get
going from 0 to 1 person,
and the average is 25.
The average is 25.
The reason why I said it that way,
is you could imagine a reality
where getting a tenth of a person,
you get a value higher than 25.
You might say,
how do I get a tenth of a person?
Well, what if one person
shows up every ten days?
Then you get a little less
benefit as you get closer
and closer to a whole person per hour.
But on average, as we
go from 0 to 1 person,
we are getting $25 of value,
or $25 of marginal revenue
per person per hour.
So if you wanted to figure
out what's the total
marginal revenue that
we got from this person
right over here,
the total incremental revenue
that this is allowing us to get,
well, it's the one person
times the average
marginal product revenue,
which is 25,
so that would give us the
area of this rectangle
right over there,
which would be $25.
Now, and you would really have to do
a little bit of calculus
to fully appreciate it,
but I think you can look
at it geometrically,
that also happens to be,
given that this is a line,
that our curve,
our marginal product revenue
is a line right over here,
that the area under this rectangle
is going to be the same thing as the area
under the orange curve.
The orange curve,
between 0 and ½ is above this rectangle
and between ½ and one,
it is below the rectangle.
The area above is the
same as the area below.
So $25 is also the area,
is also the area under this curve.
That's essentially how much benefit
the firm is getting from hiring,
from going from 0 to 1 person.
They're getting $25 of benefit.
Now, how much benefit do they get
going from 1 to 2 people?
Well, going from 1 to 2,
our change in quantity
of people per hour is 1,
and then our average
marginal product revenue
going from 1 to 2 people is $20.
So, it is $20, and so
the area is 1 times 20,
and that's also going to be the same
as the area under the curve.
So the area under the
curve right over there
is going to be 20.
Likewise, the area under the curve,
if we want to say how much ...
What's the marginal product revenue we get
going from 2 to 3 people?
Well, the average height here,
we'd essentially just say,
"What is the area between 2 and 3?"
And we can figure out that area
by saying, "Well the average height,
The average height is 15.
Multiply 15, so this height,
the average height is 15.
Multiply 15 times 1.
You get $15,
$15 of benefit.
Between 3 and 4, the average height is 10.
The average height is 10,
so you get 10 times 1.
You get $10 of benefit,
would be the area under
the curve right over here.
$10 of benefit.
Then the area under the curve there,
by the same argument, is $5.
Is $5 of benefit.
Now, we've ...
Given this, this is just
telling us the revenue
we're getting,
but it's really not telling us,
it's really not telling us
what is the optimal,
or the rational number
of employees to hire?
To do that,
we have to think about
the cost per employee,
the marginal cost that we
are actually incurring.
I mentioned earlier that
this is a competitive firm.
When I mentioned it before,
I talked about it being competitive
in terms of the car wash market,
so it was a competitive supplier,
but let's assume that it
is also a competitive buyer
in the labor market,
so these are two different,
these are two different markets,
and I want to clarify.
In the car wash market,
in the car wash market,
we are competitive,
we are a competitive supplier,
or I guess we could say
are a seller of car washes.
In the labor market,
in the labor market,
our firm is a competitive,
is a competitve buyer.
Now, I'll do a little
bit of an aside here,
because when we talk about suppliers,
there's the competitive suppliers,
where there's many undifferentiated people
who are supplying some
type of good or service
and the opposite of that was a monopoly,
so a non-competitive,
non-competitive.
As a seller, we call that a monopoly.
If we had a non-competitive buyer,
so if you had many sellers
but only one big buyer
that could have a lot of market influence,
and we haven't done a
deep analysis of that yet,
that word, just so you know it,
and you're not taken by
surprise if someone says it,
it means monopsony,
or the word is monopsony.
Monopsony.
Not relevant to this video.
We are the opposite of a monopsony
in the labor market.
We are assuming that we
are a competitive buyer.
There are many, many, many, many,
many buyers here,
so we essentially just have
to take the market wages,
and we are also the opposite of a monopoly
in the car wash market.
We're assuming that we are one of many
competitive sellers.
Monopoly means only one seller,
monopsony means one powerful buyer.
The whole reason why I'm saying
that we are competitive
in the labor market
is I'm assuming that we're
just going to have to
take the market wages,
so the market wage for the
type of labor we're hiring,
so the market wage,
and we're just going to have to take that.
The market wage is going to be,
let's just say it is $10 per hour.
$10 per hour.
Given that, what is a rational number
of people to hire?
Well, that 1st person we hire,
we're getting $25 of benefit.
The marginal cost of them,
and we can actually draw
a marginal cost curve.
The marginal cost curve
will just be flat right here
at $25.
It'll just be, sorry,
it'll be flat here at $10.
That's how much it costs us.
If we hire one person,
it costs us, the area would be $10.
If we hire 2 people,
the area would be between 0 and 2,
and under the curve,
which would be 20,
or you could say the increment
from going from 1 to 2
people is another $10,
or going from 2 to 3 people,
this area right over here is another $10.
If you go from 3 to 4 people,
this area under here is another $10,
under this green curve.
Does it make sense to
hire that 1st person?
Sure, you're going to get $25 in revenue,
and you're going to have $10 in wages,
so you're going to have $15 of benefit.
You definitely want to hire one person.
Does it make sense to
hire that 2nd person?
Well, the marginal product revenue
is going to be $20 from that 2nd person.
Your marginal cost from
that 2nd person is $10,
so you're going to make
$10 on that 2nd person,
so you should hire that 2nd person.
The 3rd person, you're
going to make $15 off them,
they're going to cost you $10 dollars,
so you're going to,
and this is all on a per-hour basis.
You're going to make $5,
so you should hire that.
The 4th person,
well, now it's interesting.
The 4th person, you're
going to make $10 in total
off of the 4th person,
but you're not,
but you're also going to have to pay $10
for that 4th person,
so it doesn't make sense for you to hire
another total 4th person.
Now, if you could,
it could make sense for you to hire
another half person,
maybe someone who shows
up every other day,
if this still holds,
or maybe someone who
shows up for half an hour,
or maybe someone who is doing this job
and also operating the cash register,
and they're kind of going in between.
Because for a half-person,
it does make sense.
A half-person is going to cost $5,
and their marginal benefit is going to be
the area under the
curve between this point
and this point,
and so we get,
so the profit from that person,
the net benefit we're going to get
is going to be this area right over here.
It would be rational to get them.
But what you're seeing is,
is it makes sense to keep increasing
the quantity demanded.
It makes sense to keep
hiring more and more people
until the marginal benefit,
or another way of saying,
the marginal product revenue curve
is equal to the marginal cost curve.
After that point, the person's costs
are higher than their benefits,
and you wouldn't want to hire them.